[Aplausos]
Cómo se sienten hoy emocionado y también
algo nervioso yo no estoy nerviosa para
nada me llamo Brian tengo 25 soy
fotógrafo y vivo en Los Ángeles Ella es
mi mamá
Soy Cindy tengo un salón de belleza y
estoy muy feliz de estar aquí hoy Espero
escoger una chica que le guste a Brian
Cindy En qué aspectos de las chicas te
fijarás hoy primero amabilidad que sea
buena muy optimista en la vida y que sea
hermosa por dentro y por fuera Confío en
ella sí
[Música]
adelante
eres tan linda todas son hermosas
mi mamá eligió a casi todas creo que no
sabe cómo funciona el juego no podía
eliminar a ninguna fue muy gracioso
gracias
[Música]
Cindy eliminaste muy pocas
tengo que escoger solamente a una al
final sí buena suerte
[Música]
muy bien listo Sí vamos a posar así de
acuerdo
se indique qué opinas
la pose Será muy linda
ven aquí de acuerdo ahora podemos
tocarnos bien de acuerdo
estoy nervioso
puedes abrazarme de lado de lado
deberíamos salir naturales y saludar qué
opinas me gusta
Gracias Quiero saber si podría
sostenerte como en el Titanic Mira hacia
arriba
[Música]
[Risas]
estuvo genial Te molestaría cargarme en
tu espalda para nada
genial
Qué lindos
[Música]
Por qué
vamos a brindar de acuerdo salud
estoy listo
vaya
pensaba en saltarnos varias partes y que
mejor te arrodillaras
[Música]
[Risas]
uno así
tal vez podríamos posar como superhéroes
del ayudante perfecto
[Risas]
muy bien Cindy hice un gran esfuerzo
Hola hola
soy Charlotte eso es esto Fabiola me
llamo kirsten estoy muy nerviosa es
amigable tranquila Cómo están bien
gracias
pregúntale Cuéntame un poco sobre ti me
llamo zenia nací en Rusia pero me mudé a
Austria y ahora vivo aquí en Estados
Unidos soy de Washington y me encanta
salir al aire libre estudio ingeniería
mecánica en la universidad Estatal de
California y me encanta el arte hice
estos zapatos los pinté yo misma es el
logo de la fraternidad a la que formo
parte también soy presidenta del club de
modas de mi facultad vaya eso es genial
soy muy atlética me gusta hacer
ejercicio
Gracias soy creativa amo pintar y el
arte en general también tocó guitarra y
amo los deportes qué deporte te gusta
más baloncesto
es difícil solo hay una respuesta
correcta En serio
sí muy bien
nací vivo en San José son vietnamitas
un par de familiares que viven en San
José es muy lindo se parece a bombata
eres vietnamita vaya
me encanta la música Los festivales y
los conciertos
hace poco yo también fui genial cual fin
de semana
fuiste ambos Sí estaba trabajando
Te gustaría seguir con el diseño cuando
me gradué me dedicaré a la ingeniería de
paneles solares y cuando tengas
suficiente experiencia me dedicaré a
diseñar mis productos también tendré una
línea de ropa propia Ese es el plan sí
soy emprendedora sí tienes mente de
negociante has tenido más relaciones en
el pasado solo he tenido dos relaciones
serias una de ellas fue con una mujer
en
realidad Terminé con ella hace unos
pocos meses ninguna de las dos tenía
estabilidad mental necesaria para estar
en una relación ahora estamos mejor
[Risas]
es tan incómodos No gracias por
contarnos me alegra mucho que me hayas
contado algo tan personal
aprecio tu honestidad es muy importante
Muchas gracias soy muy honesta es lo
mejor
estás lista para salir
con quién
en general en general
fue una pregunta directa Supongo que si
encuentro a alguien que valga la pena y
todo fluye con esta persona Estaría muy
bien
sí lo haría Gracias por allá
Hey me gustaba me gustaba Sí sí era a la
derecha
Gracias
hacia allá gracias buen placer Gracias
derecha o izquierda lo volvió a olvidar
lo siento pase Sí gracias gracias
gracias
Fue un placer creo que terminamos Qué
tal todo bien sí estás bien Brian estuvo
bien
Cindy hay algo que quieras decirles a
las chicas antes de anunciar tu decisión
todas son hermosas y si no las elegí no
significa que no me gusten todas me
encantaron pero debo escoger a una mi
corazón está latiendo mucho
[Risas]
Qué tal Bien
estoy nervioso la escogí porque te
gustan las intelectuales que sepan de
arte
esta chica es un artista
a nosotros nos encanta la moda creo que
lo hice bien ella suele decir que si
tuviese una hija la llevaría de compra
siempre me encanta la moda sí es verdad
eso es cierto
lo logramos
[Música]
Hola hola
cómo estás
Estoy bien
Fabiola cierto te sorprendió no sabía
qué esperar estoy muy feliz
qué bien
bien hecho mamá
si te gusta
escogí la que más me gustaba a mí lo
siento hija
me dejé llevar pero me gusta tanto cielo
sola
negra cuando hablo de moda y negocios mi
mamá se emocionó se nota que es
increíble si dependiera de ti hubieses
escogido a esa chica hoy
No creo pero no me molesta es muy
creativa y yo también lo soy le
escribiré y veremos qué pasa le gusta ir
de compras
cuando era muy joven y vivía en Vietnam
era diseñadora de modas me encanta
vestirme bien mis amigos me dicen que
nunca me han visto repetir ningún
atuendo en 20 años